Hello everyone, this is Steve Gilbert. Welcome to lecture 22 on C-style strings.
So let's talk about C-style strings.
A C-string is a character array that was used for traditional or built-in strings in C.
These were inherited by C++.
So if I create an array, I can actually initialize it, a char array,
I can initialize it with what we call a string literal, with just "hello" in double quotes.
That will initialize or create an array that has six elements in it.
So notice the different ways we could do that.
We could allocate it by saying "greeting6 = hello" or we could do it the same way we do all the other arrays.
We could say "greeting =" and then put in the "h" and the "e" and the "l" and the "l" and the "o"
along with one additional value.
Now notice when we initialize a C-style string or a character array,
we don't need to use braces or commas as with the additional array.
We don't need to use this third style right here.
We can just do it by putting in the string itself.
Now the array that's created when we do this occupies six bytes, not five.
It has one byte for each of the characters, the "h" and the "e" and the "l" and the "l" and the "o."
That's followed by a binary zero, the zero character.
It's not the integer zero, it's the character with the ASCII value zero.
We call this the null terminator.
You notice I've spelled null with a single "l" there.
So null is the name of the character with the ASCII value zero.
If you look at an ASCII character set, let's go see if we can find one in our web browser here.
Let's look up ASCII table.
If we look up an ASCII table, you'll notice that these characters have names.
So the character that has the decimal value zero has the name "nul."
And so that was just the ASCII name for the character that had the value zero, the ASCII character zero.
Sometimes students get that confused with "null."
An "null" is something different.
It also has the value zero, but it's the C representation of a pointer with the value zero.
We actually don't use "null" in C++. We use "nullpointer" instead, which is an entirely different type.
Now, let's look at two examples of C-style strings.
Here's the one I just showed you, "pet1 = dog."
That is the equivalent to this.
"char pet1 [] =" and then embraces initializing the D, the O, the G.
And even though in this top one we don't see the null character, that null character is actually there.
So the memories are allocated for four characters in user space.
That means in your space that you can make a change to.
So "pet1" is, its type is an array of four characters.
It's a block of four characters, and if we created this in the static storage area,
in other words, outside any function, it would be in the static area.
If we created it on the stack, in other words, inside a function, it would be on the stack.
This is slightly different.
So "pet2" is a pointer. "pet2" is a pointer, and it points to the first character of an array of four characters.
So there is still a "cat" null character out there, but that "cat" null character is not stored in your space.
It's not stored on the stack. It's not stored on the static storage area.
It's stored in a section of read-only memory, a special part of the static storage area.
Now, in C, this is allowed. In C++, this is actually not really correct.
In C++, because this is stored in a read-only memory section, C++ said,
"Well, we should allow the compiler to know that, and so we should write it as const char*."
So in C++, if you write this, you'll probably get some kind of warning or error.
Now, notice that I can take this pointer, char*pet2=cat, and I can reassign it to "pet1."
I can say "pet2=pet1," because "pet2" is a pointer. That pointer can be changed, but I could not do the opposite.
I could not say "pet1=pet2." "pet1" is fixed.
It is a constant address of the first character here.
So the standard library inherited a collection of functions in the header called "cstring."
Now, C and older C++ implementations will use the header called "string.h."
All of the headers in C++ that start with "c," like "cstring," are inherited from the C language, and the C standard library.
So let's look first at how we find the size of a string, if we want to loop through it.
With a C++ string, like "a" here, we get the length by calling "a.length" or "a.size."
We call a member function because a C++ string is an object of a class.
"b" is a C string. In other words, it's an array of 1, 2, 3, 4, 5, 6, 7, 8 characters.
And it's stored in this array on the stack, in this case.
And we will get the size by passing the array "b" to a function called "strlen."
So "strlen" is in this header file "cstring."
Now, if we want to loop through the string, with a C string, we have to use the traditional "for" loop.
You'd have to do "i < len b."
With a C++ string, we can still do this, but we can do this as well.
You can't do this with a C-style string.
So, again, C strings and C++ strings are different kinds of things.
Now, to assign or copy a string in C++, you do it exactly the same way that an integer does.
You say "string a = hello."
And to make a copy of "a," you do "string b = a."
So that means that we have two copies of the word "hello."
How do we do that in C?
Well, in C, we have one string here.
Now, notice I'm using the second time, where I have a constant character.
And this is in read-only memory.
I have an array that I'm going to copy that into, "b."
I've allocated enough space to hold it.
And I'm going to call the function in C string called "strcpy."
S-T-R-C-P-Y.
And I'm going to copy into "b" this array all the characters from "a."
Now, how this works is the loop inside the function strcpy simply copies the first character into "b."
Then it copies the second character following that, the third character, the fourth character, the fifth character.
And then it copies the null character, and then it stops.
Now, because of that, you have to make sure that the destination, here "b" is the destination where we're going to put the characters,
has sufficient space to store all of the characters plus the null byte.
Let's look at string concatenation.
So C++ string concatenation works like this.
You create a string "a," and then you add "a" to another string, "beautiful" in this case, and we create another string.
So we have one string "a" that has "hello" in it, and "b" that has "hello, beautiful."
If we want to do the same thing in C, what we have to do is create the C string we're going to copy from.
We create the C string we're going to copy to, and initialize it with the value that we're starting with.
And then we use a function called "string cat," or "strcat."
So this is string concatenation.
And it will concatenate into "b."
Now here, it's going to do the same thing.
It's going to start copying from "a" into "b," but before it does that, it's going to loop all the way down here until it finds the null byte.
And so when it copies this space, it's going to overwrite the null byte here.
And then it's going to copy the "b" and the "e" and the "a" and the "t" and so forth until it gets to the null byte here.
It will copy there, and then "b" will contain "hello, beautiful."
Again, it's entirely up to you to make sure the destination, in this case "b," has sufficient space to store all the characters from "hello"
and all the characters from "beautiful" and the null byte at the end of it.
Now, for string comparison, with C++ strings, you treat them just like integers.
If string "a" is "hello" and "b" is something that's unknown, you just say if "a" equals equals "b," just like you would with integers.
If "a" is less than "b" to see if it appears before "b" in the dictionary.
If "a" is greater than "b" to see if it falls later than "a" in the dictionary.
In C, you cannot use the relational operators.
You could use the equals equals sign, but as we saw with arrays, using equals equals with arrays is legal.
In other words, it compiles, but it's stupid. It doesn't work.
So, if we have two C strings, "a" is "hello" and "b" is whatever,
then we call the function strcmp and pass "a" and "b" to it.
If "a" and "b" have the same characters in the same order, it returns zero. There is no difference.
If "a" would appear less than "b," or in other words, it would appear before "b" in the dictionary,
then it returns a number that is less than zero.
And if "a" would appear after "b" in the dictionary, it returns greater than zero.
Now, notice strcmp is not a predicate or Boolean function.
It doesn't return true and false. It returns three values, zero, less than zero, or greater than zero.
And so it's very common to forget that. It's a common bug to think that it is a Boolean function.
And of course, because of the way C++ works, it will take that zero or non-zero and turn it into true and false.
You generally will not get the answer that you expect.
So remember when you call strcmp to test the value that's returned from strcmp.
Okay, so let's go ahead and open our first exercise.
This is a function called mincat.
We're going to use the standard C-string functions to write a function that concatenates two C-string literals.
So s1 and s2 are the two strings.
Out is an array of characters where the answer goes.
Now remember, we cannot return arrays, so we could not return a C-string.
So this is an output parameter.
Maxlen is the size of the output array.
And so we have to make sure that we don't overstep the size of that.
So here's how we're going to do that.
We're going to find the length of the shorter string and put it in the variable called len.
Then when we concatenate, we're going to concatenate only the last len characters from the longer string.
So in the problem you'll see several examples.
So let's switch over to our IDE here.
And I've already opened ic22a mincat.cpp.
I'm going to move that down a little bit and we'll look at it.
So we're going to write a function named mincat.
We're going to be given two C-string literals.
We're going to append them together.
And we're going to return the results in the third argument, a non-constant array of char.
The fourth parameter is the size of the array.
If the input strings are different lengths, then we'll omit the leading characters from the longer string
so it's the same length as the shorter string.
So if we try to concatenate "hello" and "hi", the shorter string has only two characters.
And so we're only going to use the two last characters from "hello".
And so that will concatenate as "low" and "hi".
Now the strings can be of any length.
Now if the combined string output is larger than the space available,
then we're going to divide the available space in half, after leaving room for the terminator of course,
and concatenate the last n characters from each string.
So we're going to use the functions from the C-string header.
We're not going to use any of the C++ string library.
So let's write that here.
Now notice it's not going to return anything as a function.
It's going to be really a procedure.
So we're going to call it "mincat".
It's going to take a const char * s1, const char * s2,
a char out that is going to have, we don't know how many lengths,
and a size t for max length.
Okay, so that's all we need to do to stub that out.
Let's open a terminal on that window by right clicking and open an integrated terminal.
And then let's just do "make" to make sure that it compiles.
It should, right? We haven't really done anything other than put in the parameters and everything.
Okay, so I need to know the lengths of these.
How do I find the length of s1 and s2?
So I'm going to say
size t, or int if you want,
len1 = strlen s1.
So call the function strlen.
So size t, len2 = strlen s2.
Now I need to create the length that's going to be the shorter of it.
So size t, len =
and here I'm going to use the conditional operator.
So len1 < len2
question mark, I'm going to use len1.
Otherwise I'm going to use len2.
You could use an if statement, but it would be a little bit longer and take a little bit more time.
Now, what we want to do
is we want to concatenate into out
s1 and s2
but only the len characters.
So we're going to say str
the last len characters.
So we're going to say strcopy
our first thing.
We're going to copy into out.
We're going to take len
s1
plus len1.
Now remember s1 is a pointer.
It's an address.
We add len1 to it and what are we pointing to?
We're pointing to the null byte in s2.
Now if I subtract len from that
what I have is the number of characters
for the first item.
Now I'm going to concatenate s2.
So I'm going to say strcap
not strcopy. I'm going to concatenate into out.
I'm going to copy s2
plus len2.
So move that pointer down to the end
and remove it back, len characters.
Okay, let's go ahead and try that.
Let's do make test.
And it looks like it worked except for three of them.
And that is because this only has five characters available.
So it works fine if we have an unlimited number of characters
available in the answer or out parameter.
But if we don't have an unlimited number of characters
we have a problem.
So we haven't done this second part here.
We haven't done this part right here if the combined output
is larger than the space available.
So let's do that right here.
We'll say if
if len times two
is greater than
maxlen plus one
that means it won't fit, right?
And if that's the case we have to set len
equal to maxlen
minus one. So allow to the null byte
divided by two. So each character, each string can only use
that amount of space.
Okay, let's try it again.
Let's clear that with control L and do make test.
And we got all of them working correctly.
I'm going to show you in a second something else about C style strings.
Many people say, well, you know, this is all good and fine
but why would I want to do this when I already have the C++ string class?
What can I do with this that I can't do with the C++ string class?
Well, the reason that we want to learn to use the C
string type in addition to the C++ string type
is because we want to interact with things like
the operating system. So all operating systems
from the newest, Mac OS X, Windows,
Linux, all of them are written in the C language.
And if you want to talk to the operating system,
if you want to write a Windows program, you must use
the C programming language to do that. Or some other
higher level language that translates it to C for you, like C#.
So let's look at something in B here.
PNV
and let's bring that down there, that's too high.
And let's open a terminal on B.
Open an integrated terminal so we have a fresh terminal down there. I can close the other ones.
And what we want to do
is in the operating system, this is true for Windows,
for the Mac, for Linux of course, which we're working on,
variables that are used among
different programs can be set in an area of memory called the environment.
So this is not global inside your program, it's global
outside your program. So for instance, if I want to know
actually I'll just show you what all the variables are.
So if I do printenv in Unix,
in Windows the command would just be set and hit enter,
it goes and it prints a list of those variables
and tells me what the values of those variables are.
So notice that there's a variable called githubapiurl.
There's a variable called workdeer.
There's a variable called gemhome and so forth.
And so these variables are set into
the environment. We set several of these variables when we configured
our IDE. Remember when you configure your IDE
or when you reset your IDE,
it will set things like your CS150 username
and so forth. Those are in the environment.
Well this command printenv is just a program
and it's a program that reads a global array
of character pointers and so that is written
as char star
a bracket or environ bracket
or we can write it as using simply two stars like that.
And so we are going to write a program
that does the same thing as this. And I want to show you how easy this is to do
but you have to know about C style strings.
So this variable is declared
in the operating system, is defined in the operating system
and we want to use it in our program.
So how do you use a variable in one program
that's declared in another or defined in another? You make it
external. So we're going to declare this variable.
We're not going to define it. We're going to say extern
char star star environment.
So now we can use that variable.
That variable has been declared or defined elsewhere.
We have declared it in our program and so we can use that
to connect to the operating system.
So if I dereference environment
what I get is a pointer to a character.
In other words what I get is a C style string.
And so what I want to say
is while
actually I want to create a variable. I'll call it p.
So auto p equals
environment.
In other words I don't want to change
And you might wonder why don't you put const there if you don't want to change it.
That's because in C, which the operating system was written in,
they didn't have const. They didn't use const like that.
So we're going to say auto p equals environment
while star p
while
while star p is not equal to the null pointer
we're going to print out
that variable.
Okay now this actually won't quite work
correctly. If you notice the end of this it tells us
the name of the program. This environmental variable underscore
is the name of the program we're actually running.
So we're going to compile this. The name is p_env
So we're going to say make p_env
and then we're going to run
p_env dash p_env
and we did not get what we wanted
oops, let me control c to stop it. Ah!
It crashed. So what did I forget here? I forgot the fact
that the first time we're going to be pointing to the first string but we're going to continue
to be pointing to the same string each time. So we have an endless loop
that is just pointing to the first environmental variable and
printing it over and over and over again. So
to go to the next one, what do we have to do? We have to increment the
pointer. Okay, let's build that
again
and let's run it again.
Okay, so now notice we got exactly
the same thing we had before.
My github user is sgilbertstudent
and so we have written
a program that has exactly the
same output as a
built in piece of code.
We couldn't do this with C++ strings
you have to use C style strings and pointers
to do this.
Now to process
C style strings, what you do is you treat them
exactly like an array, except
you're not worried about the length of it. You assume that there's a
terminating null character in the array. And so
instead of counter controlled loops, we're going to use a sentinel
loop, like this example of the strlen function.
So strlen here is returning an int, the actual version
of strlen returns a size T. And it's
going to create a counter i, and while
s at i is not equal to the null character, it's
going to increment i. At the end of that, i will have
the count of the number of characters in the
string. So the traditional C library string functions
all depend on that null character at the end
of the string. Now you can write your
code using array syntax. There's no loss of
efficiency, if you're more comfortable with that it's perfectly fine, but
it's more common to use pointer syntax. So here's a version
of strlen that uses pointer syntax. Notice
s is a const char star, or a pointer
to a const character. We have length, and
while star s is not equal to the null byte,
we dereference the pointer s, it's not equal to the null byte,
we increment s to go to the next character,
and we also increment the length. So we get a pointer
to a constant character, while s doesn't point to the terminating null
byte, we move s and we count the character.
So this is much more common to use pointers
with C style strings than it is with arrays. As I
mentioned though, there is no loss of efficiency if you use
array syntax. So if you're more comfortable with that, you're perfectly
fine using that.
Now, it's also very common to use a much more
concise syntax when processing C strings
with pointers. So notice this just has three lines,
the length is zero, while star s plus plus
len plus plus return len. So this is
a very, very common C string idiom.
You should recognize it and understand it. I don't necessarily encourage you to
write this kind of code. It is no more efficient than the
more understandable code on the previous page. It just took
a little bit of fewer typing. So let me just go
through why that works so you understand it.
So star s will dereference the pointer
s. Dereference the pointer s. However
this is not star s, it's star s plus plus.
And so plus plus and
star have the same precedence.
So the s has to know whether to do the plus plus first or the
star first. And because the precedence is the
same, that won't help it decide. And so it has to fall
back on what we call the tiebreaker rule, associativity, and
decide does this go left to right, star s, and then
increment it, which would mean incrementing the value
that was at s, or does it mean plus plus s
and then dereference the plus plus s.
And these are right associative.
Most operators, arithmetic operators, are less
associated. These are right associative, so the plus plus goes first
with the tiebreaker rule. Now the value
returned from s plus plus is not
the pointer s after it's been changed
it's the pointer s before it's changed, because
this is post-increment. So we take the value
that s had before it was changed, we change s
move it to the second character, return the value of s
that it had before it was changed, dereference that
and if that is not the null character
if it's the null character, this is false. If it
is the null character, then we increment
length, and finally we return length. So this stops
when it dereferences the null character.
Now again, if we look at the previous
example, here we're explicitly saying
while star s is not equal to the null character. Here
we're implicitly saying that. And so I think it's
better always to be explicit. I would prefer that you write code that is
a little clearer and easier to understand. But if you don't understand
what this does, when you actually read C code, and you
see this very common idiom, you'll be confused.
Okay, so we are going
to finish up this lecture by looking at
an example. This is from the online
C-String practice problems in, not coding
bat, in Code Step-by-Step. There's
a link on the home page. But the online version wants to use
the library functions. The version we're going to use is not going to use any
library function. It's very similar to what you'll be asked to do for
PEO8. So we're going to open
countmatches.cpp. We're going to look through an array
of C-style strings, just like we did with PN.
We're going to count the number of strings that contain the first string.
And so this is the really tricky part right here that you need to learn
to understand to do well on PEO8. How do
you see if one string is contained inside another
string? So I'm going to solve it two ways. I'm going to solve it first using
array notation, and then I'll do it using pointer notation.
It's a little easier actually with pointer notation, I think.
But you may prefer it with array notation.
So let's pop that up. Let's go ahead and
close the things we had previously.
[typing]
Okay, so
countmatches.cpp. Let's close those
two and let's open a shell on that one.
Yes, we have a shell open on C.
Okay, now notice
I'm going to put my name inside here.
You can put your name and section and date at the top
if you want. You don't have to, but this is the one that is important. So we're writing
a function called countmatches, and it accepts a string
to match, a const char char, an array of characters. So you can
really see it here. That's how it's called.
So if we know that, we know what to write here. And it's going to return the number
of times that it matches. So we'll say int countmatches
const char
star str
str
Let's call that, it has it as strs
up there, but let's call this one arrays.
So
that's our
array.
And then we're going to have a size T.
This is the length
of the array.
So that's pretty easy to loop through this array.
So let's go ahead and run this.
So we'll go for size
T, i = 0
i < n++i
And then what we want is
arr sub i and see if it contains the string.
Now instead of actually doing that,
I'm going to write a function. So I'm going to write my function
right up here, because the function is the guts of what we want.
So I'm going to say if
if contains
arr sub i
str
Here's what I want to write.
if arr
i contains str
So figuring out how to put that in a function is
hard.
Or is in
if is in
contains is nicer.
It's hard to know whether to put the arr first or the string,
but I would want to say if arr i contains the string,
then what I want to do is update my result.
So result++
Of course we haven't created our result, so int result
equals 0
and return result
So that's simple enough that that looks like it should work okay.
So the hard part of this is figuring out how to write
contains. So we're going to have
two strings. It's going to be a boolean
contains const char
star s1 and const
char star s2
and let's just return
false here.
And if we find it, we'll return true.
Okay, so we actually have enough here. We have enough to
stub it. We've stubbed it out. And so we can try it. So we can say
make test
and we see none of those
fail because it returns 0 in each case, right? It doesn't find any.
And so now
we're ready to think about contains. So contains
is going to be arr sub i and if we look at
this example right here, we'll see arr sub i is going to be
rainbow. So does rainbow contain o?
It does. So
imagine, and I said I was going to
do this two ways, right? I was going to do it with an array
and a string and so
let's do it first with an array.
Okay, so
we need to have a couple of variables.
One variable is going to go through s1.
So I'm going to do size t for these.
You can do int. It's fine.
And I'll call that i1.
And so we're going to say while
s1
at i1 is not equal to the
null character
i1++
That will walk us
through this string. That will walk us through this string.
Now we want to
at each point in here, we want to see if
s2 is at that point. So we're going to create
another variable, i2.
So size p i2
and we're going to say
while
s2
i2
is equal to
s1
i1
plus i2
because we're going to have to look at the first character here
the first character here, the second character here
the second character here, and so we're going to have to offset s1
by not only its index, but the index
of the second character.
So while those are the same
and s2
i2 is not equal to
the null character and
s1 i1 plus i2
is not equal to the
null character
we're going to increment i2
i2++
That means that at some point
we're either going to read all of s2
and this is going to fail or
the characters are not going to match
like that will immediately not match when we try to compare the o here to the r there
will drop out. So after we drop out
in other words this while loop is guaranteed to drop out
it's guaranteed to drop out
and after we drop out, if we are looking at the null
character after the end of this ow
in other words if
s2 i2 is equal to the null character
then we have found our character. So if
s2 sub i2
equals the null character
then
got a parenthesis in the wrong place there
then we're just going to return true
ok so this is doing contains
now we have actually one problem here and you'll see it here
in a minute. It actually works for most of the
characters but not for all of them. So we'll go make tests
and you can see it doesn't work for this one
and this one. So what is s2
in these two cases? It's the null string
it's the empty string and notice we have this little
sentence here. The empty string is a substring of any string
you may assume, so an empty string is a substring
of any string. So what that means is we have to say
if star
if s2 sub 0 equals
the null string, or the null byte
then it's the empty string so we're going to return
true. That means it matches any string. So we have this
special case here for this sentence right in here
and that should take us from 67%
to 100%
so that does
take us to 100%. Now let's do one more
let's do one more and that is
I want to, I'm going to leave this here so you can
see it. I'm going to change its name
to xcontains. So we won't
actually be calling it. And I'm going to
write a version of contains that only uses pointers
so bool
contains const char star
s1 const char star s2
I'm going to
say file
star
s1 is not equal to the null character
and of course you know we could write this as file
star s1. I mean that would be the same
thing.
s1++
If we get down here we're going to return false
if
star s2
equals the null character or if not
star s2 we're going to return true
and here we're going to try and do the same thing we did before
so I'm going to create a couple of pointers. I'm going to say
auto p1 equals s1
auto p2 equals s2
while star p1 equals
star p2 and
star p1 is not equal to the
null character or while star p1
and star p2 is not
equal to the null character
hold on I'm having a hard time
finding that character there
null character
we're going to do p1++ p2++
now when we get
out of this if p2
which is pointing to s2 if that is pointing
to the null byte in other words if we got out of this loop because
that was true then the
character is there so if
star p2 is equal to the null byte
return true
I find this a little bit easier mainly
because when I'm using pointers I don't have to do this addition
here of the offsets to get the value and that
part kind of always confuses me here so I find this a little bit
clearer and cleaner
in your text this algorithm is shown at the last
part of this chapter and so it's important that you learn and
memorize this algorithm so let's go ahead and copy
that or test it let's do make test
and we got 100% once
again. Okay so that's it for lecture
22 I will see you guys next time
Thank you.